[Applause]
[Music]
but a propitious beginning
for the Los Angeles Lakers
ties the largest first quarter lead in
NBA playoff history whatever they're
running I think they need to do it more
crisply than they did in the first
quarter of game two
LeBron guarded by Brooks gets downhill
little float game is pure
use the left hand and miss the layup
Lakers have numbers coming back the
other way
Reeves touch the paint and he finishes
through the hit on James old he gets
them isolated one-on-one and then the
Lakers to me are at their best running
with
LeBron off the dribble handoff action
picked up by Xavier Tillman Davis has a
mismatch LeBron slams the brakes and
he's got four quick ones
and that's what he gets you the number
one team in the league scoring eight
points he's the number one guard
let's call it a pass to LeBron and
people think about Pace they usually
think about fast break and transition
but you can have good Pace in the half
court as well Jackson Jr with the Mist
Tillman had it blocked by Vanderbilt
started by Bane
little staggered screens
Russell got to the Lane and laid it in
Bando not a shooter left it short Reeves
with the offensive board
little short jumper is good
Russell off the double drag through the
foul
they'll wave it off Mark Davis says it
was prior to the gather
I mean that's an easy call that's pick
and roll action second consecutive
possession you get D'Angelo Russell who
has been struggling mightily
here's LeBron on the slot cut got it
I think you've got to start to impact
the basketball a little bit more there's
that double drag Davis right it's
freezing off
I'm going to say if we're running that
back and it's my ball
Russell Davis with the offensive rebound
oh he said it with his chest
Holly rules A.D doing A.D things
shooting at above 40 since joining
Memphis at 13 in game two rui hashimura
continues on a hot streak with that
tongue wagon acting about 24 a game in
the first two Davis trying to turn the
corner backs down to him and light work
Jones sneaks the screen and misses the
Mark again hashiba on the break
steps through got it
Jones gave it away rui on the break
Brian first class
timeout Memphis
[Applause]
foreign